how are you doing today hi doing well
how are you
good i'm i'm sure you're enjoying the
speed dating today i am yeah
uh so i am curious which of your i'm
sure there was someone in your family or
a friend that freaked out that you were
in a marvel movie so which of your
friends and family were the most excited
that you were joining the mcu
um i definitely most of my dude friends
were were very uh
were very excited um my
my and and you know my my my family was
excited i don't think my grandma really
understands what marvel is but i i was
just trying a marvel movie and she was
like what forget it because it was a bad
connection
sure um i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of a movie what
do you think might surprise people to
learn about the making of like a big
marvel movie like this
um well i think what may surprise them
is actually how much is literally
practically being done in front of you
um there's like
it it's just such an amazing thing to
watch
happen and then i i also think that
they'd be surprised about
how how intimate it could also feel you
know especially when we're doing
non-action scenes i think they're you
know it's a really collaborative warm
feeling on set when you signed on uh how
much did kevin feige or anyone at marvel
say to you here's our long-term plans
for your character this is what we're
thinking and how much is it sort of like
just trust us
um i mean it's i definitely i think when
you first sign on to one of these things
you kind of just really pay attention to
the material at hand i i don't i don't
know any i've never been a part of a
conversation about like the kind of
long-term plan for for these characters
but uh i i really do trust i really do
trust them with what they wanted with
what they especially destined and
and um how he's how he originally saw
this this character
you are obviously very funny and i'm
curious um when i talk to a lot of funny
people i always like wondering what like
the night before you're going to step on
set are you thinking about alt lines and
other things you can say and how much is
it really in the moment you coming up
with like cool stuff that's an
interesting question i think my my whole
role with with um
with when it's when you're when it's
like makes sense to improv or go off go
off that you want to make the camera guy
laugh every time so if if you're telling
if you're saying the same line no matter
how funny it'll play if i want i want i
don't ever want him to be bored so like
that that's that's what i try to do is
just i i want to make people laugh
around me every take so that could mean
making up stuff like on the spot or
maybe the night before
if you want to do that but i think also
the longer you sit on something the less
you think it'll work
yeah i've uh i've spoken to people that
when a take is ruined on set it means
you found some gold and it probably
probably exactly
yeah for sure um so i know that you're
part of the little mermaid which is
another project i'm super excited about
what can you tease about this
um i can i can tease definitely some
some awesome music uh by lin-manuel and
uh and uh i i think that um we're gonna
have an amazing
new ariel so yeah i'm really excited to
be a part of it now that you've entered
the mcu do you sort of feel obligated
that you need to like watch everything
that's on disney plus and all the other
movies to like be paying attention and
how much is it sort of like this is a
lot
um you know i i don't i mean i i don't
think it's necessarily an obligation
when like they're genuinely enjoyable
and you know
uh but no i think that it definitely is
a lot you want to make sure that
you are you're coming into it knowing
exactly what you're coming into but
uh it's just it really just
i'm really just grateful to be a part of
the mcu in general
cool i gotta go i'm just gonna say i
wish you nothing but the best and hope
it's a huge hit
thank you